[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Without
further ado, I'm
going to introduce Nadia Lopez.
In 2015, she was the
principal and founder
of Mott Hall Bridges
Academy, a school in one
of America's
poorest communities.
And she rose to fame when
the blog, Humans of New York,
featured an eighth-grader
from her school who,
when asked, who influenced
you the most in life,
responded with, my principal.
The post became a huge hit,
received over 1 million likes
on Facebook, and really thrust
Dr. Lopez and her school
into the spotlight.
And she's going to be
talking to us today
about her book, "The
Bridge to Brilliance,"
which really
chronicles educators
who are trying to
improve opportunities
for all of America's children.
So without further ado--
Dr. Lopez.
[APPLAUSE]
NADIA LOPEZ: Can
you all hear me?
Good.
So good afternoon.
I just got back from Dubai.
I was there for a week.
I was selected last year as
one of the top 50 educators
in the world from an
organization called the Varkey
Foundation.
They host what's called
the Global Teacher Prize.
And so they convened all of us
together in the beautiful city
of Dubai to be in a think
tank, to improve education,
to talk about some
of the challenges.
And while I was
there yesterday, I
was invited by
Dr. Abdulla who is
in charge of an organization
known as the Knowledge
and Human Development Authority.
And pretty much what they do
is, kind of, like the chancellor
of New York, they
evaluate and support
schools that are
located inside of Dubai.
Immediately, when I walk in--
and the reason why I'm starting
this is to build up to
what my presentation
and my conversation
really is about--
is that you walk in, and it's
like when I walked into Google
the first time.
This space is where people
are happy to be at work,
and it's unconventional.
It's not like what you've been
taught when you were in school,
that everything will
be a desk and chairs,
and everyone will
be to themselves.
It's actually a space
where people convene,
and the culture is, we
are here to work together
collaboratively.
We are here to solve
world problems.
We are here to make life better.
And we are here to enjoy it.
So yesterday was
international Happiness Day.
I don't know if you are
aware of that, but it was.
And so they had a whole
bunch of balloons,
and the guy who's on the
bike is actually the greeter.
And he goes around, and
he gives people envelopes
filled with happiness notes.
You can walk in.
You write a happy note to
someone, and he goes around,
and he just distributes it to
anyone who is in the space.
I happened to get
a load of balloons
and stand in this space as
well and celebrate with them.
And I will say this.
Like, I just
imagine what it will
be like for kids to
walk into a space
and have balloons
that are presented
to tell them that they are
indeed honored and to be happy.
And then, there is a space
where you can recalibrate
your mind and center your soul.
And they actually
told me that they
got this idea because
someone came to visit Google.
And when they
walked in, they said
this is what education
should feel and look like.
So my conversation
is about my book,
"The Bridge to Brilliance."
But I'm really going to
take you through the context
of what it is to be in a
community like Brownsville,
and why I created a space in
which I want children to really
be happy, so that they can
really strive for success.
Just to give you a little
bit of background context
about Brownsville, Brooklyn--
Mott Hall Bridges Academy.
We have 203 scholars in
sixth to eighth grade.
97% of them are
Black and Latino.
87% have free or reduced lunch.
30% have been
identified and diagnosed
with some type of
special need, so they
have an individualized
education plan.
But if I can put it on paper
and evaluate all of my scholars,
I would tell you, it would
be more along the lines
of 65% who have special needs.
88% of our scholars come in with
a kindergarten-to-third-grade
reading or math
capability level.
In the seven years that I've
been open, we've lost $600,000.
We've lost a little bit
more, but rounding it
out-- $600,000 in terms
of our allocation.
And that's really because
we have to compete
with charter schools.
So let me be very clear.
I'm not against charter schools.
I'm all about providing
children with opportunities
and the ability to have the
best education possible.
What I am against
is when we start
to target schools and
talk about what we're not
doing in terms empowering
children, as opposed
to coming together
collaboratively
to improve instruction,
to share resources.
And let me be clear
on that as well.
If my budget is $2 million,
and my salaries for teachers
is $1.5 to $1.8
million, I'm only
left with, maybe,
$300,000 for anything else
to run the school.
A charter school may have
a budget of $6 million.
They get the same
$2 million that I
would get to run the
school, but they're actually
able to fund-raise.
And people who
are on their board
can fund-raise money
and get them grants.
I don't have that luxury.
So when we talk about
equity and education,
and we talk about what
public school is not doing,
we need to have an authentic
conversation about what's
lacking in terms of support, the
access, and the opportunities.
61% of my teachers
have zero-to-five years
of teaching
experience, and 39% who
have more than that have
worked at failing schools.
I put that in there
because it's very important
that you understand.
My teachers who come to me that
are new teachers who have zero
to five years don't
have teaching experience
anywhere else.
So what my teachers
don't understand
is that we're really the
country club of education.
My school, the space,
how it's created,
is not the challenging
space of when
I came up as a school teacher.
My teachers don't know what
it's like to be in a space
when an administrator
demeans and demoralizes you.
My teachers don't know
a space where teachers
are allowed to
disrespect children,
and children are allowed
to disrespect teachers.
My teachers do not know what
it's like not to have supplies,
because I don't take any
additional money past what
I make, and I do not pay any of
the administrators additional
money past what they
make on a yearly salary,
to make sure that we have
everything that we need.
So I work from 7:30 to
8:00, 9:00, 10:00 at night.
My hours are 7:30 to 3:30.
Technically, I'm
entitled to overtime.
But this is my work, and
I feel that because I
serve these children, because
this is my life's calling,
I'm not going to
take a dime extra.
My teachers, however, because
they work for a union,
are entitled to make $45.66
extra after they've worked
six hours and 20 minutes.
So if I ask my teachers
to stay after school
to do any additional work, if
they host any type of clubs,
if they run any teams, they
are entitled to make $45.66.
That's additional money that
comes out of our budget.
The 39% of the teachers who
came from failing schools,
they understand it.
They get it.
They know that they're
in a country club,
and they appreciate the space.
But they're also in a
place of, they want more.
They want the opportunities
for leadership.
And when you're
in a small school,
you often have to worry
about it taking one person
to do three or four jobs.
So I have to manage the
space in which I don't want
my teachers to feel burned out.
I want them to know that
they're in a space where
we love and care about them
just as we love and care
about the kids, but I want them
to be able to thrive as well.
So Brownsville, Brooklyn is
about one mile square radius.
We have 80,000 residents.
Only 32% of our residents
have a high school diploma,
only 14% have a
bachelor's degree,
and only 3% have a master's.
We have the highest crime
rate in all of New York City.
We have the lowest
parental involvement.
So out of the 203 kids that I
have, that attend my school,
I am lucky if I could
get five parents
in for a
parent-teachers meeting.
Not a principal's meeting--
but at our PTA meetings,
we only get five parents.
In order to do
anything in the school,
we need seven
parents for a quorum.
In order to make any changes,
we need seven parents
for a quorum on our PTA.
We only get five parents.
So unfortunately, my
PTA can't get as much
as they would like done.
So they have to trust
that I as a principal
will do what's in the best
interests of their children.
The average income is $11,000
in the housing developments.
So those projects-- we
have the most projects
in all of the United States.
$11,000-- on the
outskirts, though,
which are the small residential
homes, it's $28,000.
They say, to live in New
York City, at minimum,
you need $45,000.
How many of you can
live off of $11,000?
Maybe for some of you
when you were 15 or 14,
but not as an adult. And
many of our residents,
our children
included, have never
ventured beyond their community.
I also want to
press upon you this.
We have the highest health
risk in all of New York City.
HIV and AIDS is the
highest in Brownsville--
the average age range, 11 to 21.
I'm going to say it again--
11 to 21 .
Highest in cholesterol,
highest in heart disease,
highest in asthma,
highest in cancer.
So on top of not having healthy
living, healthy nutrition--
on top of all of these other
things, you think to yourself,
wow, this is in
Brooklyn, New York.
How many of you have
been to Brooklyn?
OK.
Downtown Brooklyn--
now Downtown Brooklyn
is known as DoBro or
something like that?
I don't even know.
Like, I'm so against it.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
Because I'm Brooklyn
all day, and I'm like,
it's Downtown Brooklyn.
But you think about it.
Here are all of these great
erected buildings with glass--
Century 21, Target.
It's phenomenal.
You go to Williamsburg.
People are hustling
and bustling.
And then, you go to Brownsville,
and none of that is happening.
You don't feel
excited to be there.
You're surviving.
So our challenges--
as I stated, highest
density of housing
developments in New York City.
We lack safe places.
So in the summertime,
kids stay in their houses.
Idle hands, idle minds
become dangerous.
We have a lot of shootings
that happen in the summertime.
Schools are competing
for other children,
so we have to compete
with charter schools.
And smart but not
so smart for us--
charters now start at fifth
grade for their middle schools.
So what that means
is, it undercuts
us who start at sixth grade.
So they start to look
at public schools,
take the kids from
fourth grade, and have
them come into the
schools at fifth grade.
I'm looking for kids when
they start sixth grade.
Most of the time,
when I get the kids,
it's because they didn't make
it in the charter schools.
So let me give you a
little inside track.
October 31 is when our budgets
close in New York City.
OK?
So whoever's sitting
in our classrooms,
if I have all of you
in here on October 30,
I get money for each
and every one of you.
If you have special
needs, they give
me, about, $10,000 per child.
If my child doesn't have
special needs, it's $4,500.
And I'm gonna give you
context about the money
as well, in terms
of the numbers.
Now, charter schools--
November 1st, that child
whose behavior is not
something we can manage--
they may need services
that we can't provide.
The parent isn't
really supportive.
On November 1st, that
child is coming to me
without any of the money
that has been allocated.
So I have to service this
child without the money.
Right?
But the charter school
gets to keep the money.
Now, here's the
other thing about it.
New York City Department
of Education--
we have a lot of people
in a lot of offices.
Those of us who are
in schools, we're
paying for those people
who are in offices.
In charter schools, the
actual money that's allocated
for children per state--
let me give you a round-about--
maybe, $12,000 per child.
Right?
So if I have a
charter school, I'm
going to get $12,000 per child.
Because the idea is
that charter schools
are supposed to get their
own buildings that they're
supposed to pay for.
They're supposed to lease them
or build them, whichever way.
In a New York City public
school, as a principal,
I only get $45,000 per child.
New York state
allocates $12,000.
If I'm in a charter
school, I get $12,000.
If I'm in a New York City
public school, I get $4,500.
That's because as a New York
City public school principal,
we're actually paying for
all of the other people who
are working in the
Department of Ed.
But charter schools
are co-located
in our public buildings, so
they don't have to pay rent.
They don't have
to lease anything.
That's why they end up
with more money than us.
Right?
All they do is pay $1.
That was under Mike Bloomberg--
$1 to use our spaces.
So when you hear the
arguments, no one
ever has those conversations.
So we're always
at a disadvantage.
Despite all of
that, I still wanted
to open a school
to close a prison.
Because I get it.
I understand that it's systemic.
I understand that those who
are not in the education system
have no idea.
And all you hear are
the people who complain,
the people who tell the story,
the narrative that makes them
feel good to push an agenda.
But at the end of
the day, I'm dealing
with children who survive
every single day, who
are not asking you to
save them, but need
access and opportunity.
And the reason why my
children aren't what
they call proficient and
they're not doing extremely well
is because we're not
dealing with the issues
that they're dealing with
on a day-to-day basis.
The post-traumatic
stress disorder
that comes with poverty,
that comes with the fact
that when you don't have a
parent in a household or you
have parents in the household
who are as young as 20, 18, 19,
or you have five,
six, seven eight
siblings in a household,
that's a lot to undertake.
And so we can complain
about what parents should do
and what we should do with
this community, but I live it,
and I breathe it
every single day.
So it's about, what
are we going to do
in terms of turning this into
an opportunity for solutions.
And so my belief is,
I want to make sure
that children take
over this world
and become globally competitive.
Because the reality is
that every job is not
going to be here in
the United States,
and they need to have
opportunities of going abroad.
But they need to be able
to become accepting--
not just tolerant but
accepting of others,
be able to communicate,
be able to empathize,
be able to show
respect, and be loving.
I need to have teachers who are
passionate about what they do,
and not there just because
they're trying to figure out
what they are going to do.
That's part of
opening up a school,
because there are a
lot of people who say,
I want to teach.
Any of you tried
teaching before?
Yeah.
Great to be at Google, right?
[LAUGHTER]
It's hard, yes?
It's hard.
So it feels good.
It feels like this is
a great opportunity
to do something to
help someone else,
but you're not learning
that in school.
You're not learning
the real context of,
there are some real
issues you have
to deal with before you can
even get to the content.
And how do you deal with that?
How do you deal with poverty?
How do you deal with children
who can't read on grade level?
How do you deal with not
having enough supplies?
How do you deal with
that administrator who
could care less about
what you're doing
and doesn't support you?
How do you deal with crazy?
There should be a class,
Crazy 101, Public Education.
But it doesn't exist.
I also needed to make
sure that parents
are aware of what's going on
in Mott Hall Bridges Academy
and trust the process.
I told you, I get five parents
in, but I bet you this.
All 203 kids-- their
parents trust me.
They won't show up.
A lot of them just trust me.
They'll show up for graduation.
They'll give me a hug.
The entire family will be
there, and they'll say to me,
Ms. Lopez, we love
you, thank you,
and all these great things.
And I always try to remind
them, it doesn't stop here.
I fought for your child even
when you weren't present.
But your child is going to
enter high school, where
they're going to have to
just defend themselves,
and we tried our
best to support them,
to help them navigate, to
advocate for themselves.
You can't trust the system.
So I thank them all the time.
They're giving me the
most precious gifts,
which is their child.
But they shouldn't trust
everyone with that.
I have a 15-year-old daughter.
People see me coming
in her school building,
it's like-- oh, god, hi,
Ms. Lopez, is everything OK?
No, I need to see
such-and-such teacher.
Let me tell you, the
first thing they'll say
is, um, you can take
the elevator upstairs.
No one will escort me.
It's just like,
we don't even want
to be part of the conversation.
Because they get it.
I don't show up unless
there's a real issue.
I'm my daughter's advocate.
I understand the
importance of education,
and I get that from my
parents, who are immigrants.
A little background about me--
my mother is from Guatemala,
and my father is from Honduras.
They do not have a formal
education, in terms of-- they
didn't go to high
school, and they
didn't get a college degree.
All they did was come
here with the belief
that opportunity exists.
They met at a
party in the Bronx.
My mom played
hard-to-get, and my dad
was not going to accept no.
Six months later, they got
married, and they had me.
My mom had five miscarriages
before she gave birth to me,
so I'm her miracle baby,
because I was a preemie.
So when it came to
education, my mother
found whatever school that
was going to nurture me,
but she also understood
that it didn't exist
in our immediate districts.
The best school was
literally three blocks away,
but it was in another
district, so my mom had
to ask a neighbor
to write her lease,
just so I could
go to that school.
Had my mom not
done that, I don't
know if I would be standing
here today, doing the things
that I'm doing.
It was the teachers
that she trusted.
It was the space
that she created.
It was the
opportunities that they
provided for me that allow
me to know what is possible.
Because I lived
during the crack era.
I lived during the times
that there were gangs running
rampant in New York City.
And despite that,
my parents felt
like we made it through poverty
in Guatemala and Honduras.
You're going to
get on the train,
and you're going
to figure it out.
Mind your business.
Don't talk to anybody.
Call us when you get home.
We didn't have cell phones.
You better be in the house
at 3:30 when we call you.
Right?
When that phone rings,
pick up the phone.
And that's what I learned.
But it was also
during middle school
when my parents separated
that I found the saving
grace of a school building
with adults who cared enough
about me, and who let me stay
there until 9:00 at night.
So when I talk about staying
in my school building,
I've been doing
it since I was 11.
And when I created a school
where children can stay
until 6:00, 7:00 at night--
even 10:00 if they want to,
it's because I understand
that by creating that
space, I'm making sure
that a young lady is not
going to get pregnant,
that a young man is not
going to end up getting shot,
and that he's not going
to be recruited by gangs.
That's my reality
every single day.
So off of my experiences,
I've created a space
where I wanted to believe
that children would be happy
and that they understood
that they were honored.
And so one, it
starts with my team.
A great leader understands that
it can't be done by themselves.
I mean, I could go by myself.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I could.
However, I need to have a team.
So I get to choose my teachers.
I want to be very
clear on saying this.
I always say I want to be clear,
because it's also going online.
Everyone is not made
for every single space.
So those of you who tried
out teaching and figured,
this isn't really for
me, I'm that person
that helps you understand
this really isn't for you.
Let's figure out what
you're really good at.
The reason why I do that
is because I actually
sat in spaces with adults--
principals who
would take the time
to assassinate the
character of teachers
and go after their license.
I don't think that's fair.
You might do better on
the Upper West Side.
You may do better
with high school.
You may do better with
elementary school.
Middle school is a beast.
Children are very sassy.
They can be very defiant.
They have little personalities,
but they're trying
to figure themselves out.
It takes a special
type of person
who can love them
through all of that--
and a lot of patience.
OK?
So I'm that person who
will help you identify,
is this the profession for you?
Or maybe we need to go
to another great level.
But I also want my teachers
to develop a sense of trust,
because we are a team.
So I used a good analogy
with my team, maybe,
three weeks ago, where we
talked about the Super Bowl.
Any of you watch the Super Bowl?
Some of you?
OK, so you know that
the Patriots won, right?
Everybody knows that?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
And Atlanta was
actually ahead, yes.
And the biggest upset was
that the Patriots won.
But I wanted my
teachers to understand,
something happened in that game.
Because by all
sense of accounts,
Atlanta should have
won, by the numbers.
But something happened as a
turn of events on the field.
So we watched the videos,
about, six minutes off
of YouTube, where they watched
from the beginning to the end.
So even my Spanish teacher
who's in the corner, who doesn't
understand American football--
she understood the gist.
You got to get the
ball on the other side,
and there are points.
That's how we
described it to her.
She understood.
And so part of the understanding
was that great teams--
even when you feel
like you're failing,
you still push through.
You don't give up.
You don't let the other
person see you sweat,
but you also have
studied your opponent.
So you have to study the kids.
Even when they're failing and
you feel like you're failing,
you have to find that there's
something, some good potential
that's within that room that's
going to give you a winning
moment.
Atlanta, on the other
hand, got really
excited by what they thought
was going to be their win.
They stopped paying
attention to the game.
They got too comfortable.
At the end of the day, when you
have a Tom Brady on your team,
if it's not the
last three seconds,
and you're on the other
side of the end zone,
you don't celebrate.
Ultimately, a lot of teachers
get happy and keep their eyes
off of the ball.
And when things
don't go their way,
they don't know
how to transition.
When they're faced with kids
who can't read on grade level,
they can't figure it out.
They haven't
studied their craft.
They haven't mastered
the strategies.
They haven't asked for help.
They become isolated, then what
they become is very defensive.
And then, ultimately,
they give up.
I don't want anyone to ever
feel that way, not in our space.
The next thing we do is, we do
a lot of branding at the school.
We use a lot of positive words.
So in this particular
case, Occupy Schools
became part of our movement.
Every single one of our
scholars gets a t-shirt
every single year.
We do it during December
because oftentimes,
when they go on
break, they're not
going to get anything
for Christmas-- vacation,
Christmas gifts or
whatever they celebrate.
I want them to know
that this is going
to add on to their uniforms.
I want them to be reminded
how much I love them,
and I can't wait to see them
come back in their new shirts.
And it also takes the burden
off of some of their parents
who can't afford to purchase
additional uniform tops.
So Occupy Schools reminds
our parents, our staff,
our scholars, of the importance
of being in our school spaces.
If you're not there, if you do
not show up, you don't learn.
If our teachers don't
come to school on time,
if they don't show up, it's
like miss a minute, miss a day--
our kids are going
to miss a lot.
If our parents
never show up even
if it is to just
contact me, you'll
never know what's going on.
I also call my scholars
Brownsville Brilliance.
Can anybody tell me how
a diamond is created?
Pressure, right?
A lot of pressure.
I want my kids to
be reminded, there's
a lot of external pressure--
the pressure of people who are
not going to believe in you,
the pressure of the gangs,
the pressure of drugs,
the pressure of
the prostitution,
the pressure of the
health risk, the pressure
of just breathing some days.
But with all of that, you're
exceptional, you're resilient,
and you are
Brownsville's Brilliance.
No one can ever deny that
or take that away from you.
So don't see Brownsville as
this place that's negative.
See it as a place that-- shows
you're a survivor, and not
too many people can do that.
The next time someone
tries to speak badly
about where you come from,
tell them, come meet you there.
I bet you they won't show up.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
Turn the negative into
something positive.
I always tell them, my value
is because of Brownsville.
If I worked in Park Slope--
no disrespect to Park Slope--
no one ever comes up to
the Park Slope teacher
and says, oh my God, wow,
you work in Park Slope?
How do you do it?
They don't say that.
I say I work in Brownsville.
It's like, oh, my god.
How do you do it?
God bless you.
God should have blessed
me in either space.
Right?
But it's seen as, that's
not what I could do,
so thank you for doing it--
which is, kind of, good, because
I guilt people into helping me.
So you won't come to
teach, but can you
come to the school to talk to
the kids for two hours, though?
Can we do that?
Or can they come
visit your space
so that they can see what
their opportunities are?
And people will say, yes,
quicker than that, than to me
saying, can you come
teach for a week?
Uh, a week?
What?
Right?
We also celebrate College
Week at our school.
So many of our kids
are never going
to understand how amazing
it is to go to college.
They're never going to have
those conversations sitting
at the kitchen table.
They're never going
to know what it's
like to go to alumni weekend.
They're never going
to know what it's
like to join a
sorority of fraternity
or have those conversations
that usually are had when
your parents' friends come over,
or your parent has that hat,
or they're having a great
conversation about what
it was like to go to school.
So we have to do
it for our kids.
There was a conversation with a
realtor who came to the school
and said, how is it possible
that we could create all
these great schools
in New York City,
we give these kids everything
that they could possibly want,
they get to college,
and then they drop out?
And I asked him,
have you ever asked
the kid who dropped out,
why they dropped out?
Of course, he was silent.
I said, it's called,
culture shock.
Here's the thing
people don't tell us
whose parents have
never gone to college--
hey, you've got
to pay for books.
If I've gone to public
school, my books
have been given to
me every single year.
Now, I have to pay,
like, $150 for a book?
That if I got someone's
book last year,
but it's now changed, so
these pages are different,
so I can't even follow, so I've
really got to get the book?
Has anybody told me that by
the time we get to November
and it's midterms
and I'm going to be
eating cold pizza and coffee
and soda to get through?
However, if I've lived
under public assistance,
we don't have--
there's a different
way of surviving,
and we don't drink that.
We have, like, family
opportunities where we're
eating different types of food.
Do you ever think about that?
Have you ever
thought that you're
taking a child away from a
space where they feel included
to get to another space
where they feel excluded,
and no one ever
prepares them for that?
And he looked at
me and said, no.
Yeah, that's why,
oftentimes, kids drop out.
But then money runs
out, or the education
that they received
in high school
was not on par with what they
needed to get through college.
And so you take remedial classes
in college, the money runs out,
and you can't continue on.
I said there are
so many factors.
Kids don't just
want to drop out.
It's not what they
do waking up--
I just want to drop out today.
So he realized that there had
to be a different way of college
and career readiness.
And so when I
started my school, it
was about needing to make sure
that kids know that teachers
actually went to college.
Because we never talk about
where we went to school.
They go to the doctor's office.
Doctor wants you to know that
they went to Johns Hopkins,
they went to Columbia--
they put it up.
Hello!
And it's big, right?
If you ever went to
a doctor's office,
especially pediatrician,
they're making
sure you know where they went.
Same thing as a lawyer--
it's like a badge of honor
to say which school you went to.
You go into a teacher's space--
there's nothing that
says we went to college.
We went to college.
Put your degrees up.
Dust them off.
Bring them in.
Take pictures.
If you were in a
sorority or fraternity,
put them on your wall, and let's
have conversations around that.
And then, wear
your paraphernalia,
and just, like,
boast for the day.
Like, yeah, I went
to this school.
What?
You want to come?
Right?
And the kids are like, oh,
I want to go to that school.
And how I get a
t-shirt like that?
And that also
prepares us for when
we go to places like
Harvard, or we go to Yale,
or we go to Columbia, or
we go to City College,
or we go to Vassar--
that they're having
those experiences,
and now they know what to ask,
because we start preparing them
from sixth grade.
Financial aid-- are there
support groups there?
What's the
teacher-to-student ratio?
We want them to be able to
understand the language, again,
to navigate.
Building literacy
skills-- we recognize
that kids like to be
on their iPads and all
this other great stuff,
so how do we make sure
that we start to create an
opportunity where they can
use technology and still read?
Because our kids don't have
the opportunity of often going
to the libraries, because
the libraries are embedded
within the projects,
and the projects are
segregated by gangs.
And no one dared to think about
that, especially our boys.
There are literally
streets they cannot cross,
because they may
stand being killed.
We use Google Hangout sessions
so that they can communicate
with people around the world, or
even locally at their offices.
So we try to use technology
where kids understand that it's
not just for Facebook,
Instagram, or Snapchat
where they're just doing
all of their craziness.
But how can we engage
in good conversation?
Hey, you can still dance while
you're on Google Hangout,
but let's do it for something
positive and engaging.
My teachers lead
professional development.
They're the experts.
Share what you know.
Take the opportunity to
give to your colleagues.
Develop a collaborative
community within yourselves.
Now, because of
the money that we
raise from Humans of New York,
we split the money three ways.
Our scholars, in addition
to our legacy group--
I had to create a legacy group,
because my graduates were like,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
We graduated before
this money came in.
We want to go to college, too.
Sure, we continue on the legacy
of them going to college,
so I literally take them
on college tours and trips
during February and
April, when we're
supposed to be on spring
break and mid-winter break.
And then, they come in
once a month for check-ins,
but they're usually
there once a week just
to come into the
building to have a place
to study and hang out.
But we do the college trips.
We also do a summer
steam, because the kids
are so far behind.
We want to make sure
that they're actively
working and learning.
So for five weeks, 8:30 to 3
o'clock, Monday through Friday,
the scholars are in classes.
They're not your
typical boring classes--
not to say that my teachers
teach boring classes,
but the reality is that there
are high-stakes exams that they
always have to get
prepared for, that
deprives them of what really
teaching is about and learning
is about.
Right?
So we try to create a balance.
By summertime, it's the
most amazing classes
that you can imagine.
So our sixth graders last
year learned horticulture
in urban settings.
Because I explained to you--
highest risk of health issues.
So they need to understand
the importance of why
we have a community garden.
They need to understand why
you have to have healthy eating
habits, and how that needs to
turnkey to their family members
and the community at large.
So they actually present
their information.
They actually plant
in the garden.
Our seventh graders
learn social justice
through the analysis
of Black Lives Matter--
not just Black Lives
Matter 2016, 2017,
but since slavery up until now.
What has gone on?
Why does history continue
to repeat itself?
And how do you engage in
understanding to protest,
but making sure your protest
is in a way that is nonviolent,
that is cohesive, that
people can understand
what your ask is going to be?
And how do you galvanize
everyone around you
to support what you're saying?
So we have partnered with
the US attorney's office.
Our scholars got to see
and speak to judges,
look at trials, and
then do a presentation
and create their own magazine
about some of the issues that
are happening in their community
as their way of demonstrating
social justice.
Our eighth graders get
prepared for the high school
exam as well as regents.
So my eighth graders
have the opportunity
of taking the math
regents, because I
need them to be ahead by the
time they get into high school,
so that instead
of taking algebra,
they can take geometry.
Because a lot of
them are behind,
because they're over-aged.
Our scholarly discussions--
which is important.
They need to understand
how to present themselves.
They need to have real
working skills, in terms of,
this is what we do when
we are in real life.
You get up, you
talk, and you share.
Expanding horizons-- we
have a lot of partnerships
with amazing individuals.
So this is actually the
wife of Brandon Stanton
of Humans of New York, Erin.
She has a-- if you go on
Instagram or Facebook,
it's called Susie the Dog.
She rescues a lot of
over-aged animals or animals
who are going to be euthanized,
and try to get them homes.
So she's really into
veterinarian science,
and teaching children
to love and ways
of being humane to animals.
She runs a program
out of our school.
Our kids get to go
to the canine unit.
They've gone to an
overnight disability farm,
so they actually stayed
upstate New York to look
at animals who are disabled.
Talk about being
empathetic, not only
to people, children who have
special needs in your children,
but look at what happens
to animals as well.
So they get to see
that, and now, you
have so many of my kids who
want to become veterinarian
scientists.
Because of it, I now have
networking opportunities
and partnering with St.
George's University--
that's in Grenada-- which
allows my kids, one day,
to go to that school to
study veterinarian science.
And those kids who are from
Grenada, whose parents are
from Grenada, would have
guaranteed seats, in terms of,
they don't have to
pay the high cost.
They see it as an investment
creating a pipeline
and understanding that education
is beyond the reach of just
one immediate community.
Digital Day-- I love this day.
We shut down the
day of the school,
and we bring in people from all
types of digital tech spaces.
Because there are
too many buzzwords
that go around-- tech,
digital, tech, digital.
I'm a principal.
I would love to know what
everybody in this room does,
but I don't know what you do.
So I need you to come and
tell my kids what you do,
so that they can say,
maybe I can do that, too.
They only become what they see--
teachers, doctors, lawyers.
Maybe they want to
be a police officer,
but they don't subscribe to say,
I want to be in tech spaces,
or I want to work from Google.
Outside of just Google
me, know that there's
somebody behind that.
There are people working
in amazing spaces
that you need to be in.
We have guest speakers, people
who come in, like I told you.
Everyone that you
see are my friends
or I found them on
Twitter, and was like,
hey, I've been following you.
Can you come to the school?
Great thing about social media.
We have mentorship and
career exploration.
New York Times would never
write a positive article
about Brownsville.
I was getting so tired of doing
Google Brownsville and this is
what will come up--
everything negative.
And I said, the only way you
can combat something negative
is by creating
your own narrative.
So my friend, Syreeta Gates, who
has done a lot of amazing work
with a lot of publications,
helped my scholars
to develop their own magazine.
So she mentored them.
She explained to them
the different facets
of what makes them magazine.
And then, we created an online
magazine called, "The Score"--
68 pages, brilliant, pictures.
It was beautiful.
You can actually go
online, you can Google it,
and it will come up--
created by scholars about their
community in a positive light.
And because of this, when
the New York Times writer
came to our school, she saw
it, and she saw alongside it
an article that was written
by one of her counterparts.
And she says, why do
you have a magazine?
I said, because you keep
writing the wrong things.
So if I don't see it,
I have to create it.
She took it back to
her editor-in-chief,
and as a result, they did
a feature on our school.
December 15, 2014--
before Humans of New York.
It was the first
time they had ever
published something positive
about a community collectedly.
We do our young men
empowerment summit.
We do it for young
women as well,
but it's something powerful
about our young men
of color, knowing that they
matter each and every day.
So we have a mantra
for them to say,
because the media does not
remind them that they matter.
We did this before
Black Lives Matter.
President Obama had--
what was it-- my
brother's keeper.
We used to have
that in our school,
and it was not successful.
The minute we changed it,
and we wanted our boys
to affirm to themselves that
they have value in this world,
that people will be
willing to invest in them
and come and speak
to them, we ended up
with 250 to 300 young
men as part of a cohort.
They go through five
distinct classes per year.
21st-century college
career readiness--
they learn coding,
they learn web design,
and they learn music production.
My scholars have
culinary art classes.
They have photography.
They also have lab rats where
they get to dissect animals.
They have chess.
I told you, I lose
a lot of money.
But I make a lot of good friends
If I don't know anything else,
having relationships
is like capital.
Your network becomes
your net worth.
98% Graduation rate
for a community
where children have been known
to see their family members not
make it through high school--
and here we are,
building a legacy.
So these are my
graduates-- some of them.
We were at Columbia University.
These are the proud moments.
These are the reasons
why you create a space
in which children are happy.
The one great thing
about visiting your space
is that I get inspired to see
people happy to be at work,
to have choices and opportunity.
I want my kids to
see that despite what
they see every single day in
Brownsville that tells them
what they can't do.
I want them to know
that they can and will
take over this world.
I want them to also know
that when they receive,
they have to give back.
Because the only way to
transform your community
is not by getting
and then leaving,
but you actually have to come
back and set your own legacy
to impact the next generation.
I am blessed.
I started off by explaining
to you that I was in Dubai,
and also the fact
that I was able to be
in a space that has been
impacted by what someone
saw here in Google.
But it's because of the
brilliance of my scholars.
It's because of the success
that we were able to achieve.
It's because we
created this space that
allows them to be happy
that they are actually
able to live this amazing life
while they're in my building.
So I know I've
spoken a lot, and I
don't want to end without
people going to the mic.
But I'm going to close it out.
If you have any questions, you
can definitely go to the mics
now.
I don't want people
to be shy and saying,
no, I don't have anything,
and then as I'm leaving,
people are gonna be like, so
what you said was so amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
So I just wanted to ask
you-- because that's
what happens all the time.
Someone in this room probably
needs to hear that question
or would ask me
the same question,
so don't be afraid
to come to the mic.
But no, you've inspired me,
and I thank you for that.
So I'm going to take
you on this side,
and then you on that side.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I live in Brooklyn.
Actually, in Fort
Greene, [INAUDIBLE]
Hill, the very quickly
gentrifying neighborhood
where houses are
millions of dollars now.
And the school that's
my neighborhood school
is a school where the principal
has berated the teachers.
And so now, I would love
to be the person that
helps to turn
around that school,
but that is such
a daunting task.
And I feel super guilty about
it, but now, I've opted out.
And I would love to
hear, what can we do?
What can I do, and
what is possible to do
within this really ridiculously
complicated and totally unequal
system of resources of people?
And where can we get
more people like you
to take the place of
principals that berate teachers
and an administration that
doesn't feel like they
want to engage.
NADIA LOPEZ: So
ironically enough,
my teaching experience
started in Fort Greene.
And that's why I
know that that's
a place where people have been
allowed to demean children.
So it starts with leadership.
Right?
Leadership sets the tone,
and it was the leader.
And then, there were
just people who, I feel,
were the little cronies who
felt like the only way we can
survive is to be the same way.
And it was so toxic.
So I'm going to tell you
that after three years,
I had to leave.
I wanted to leave
the first year,
but it was before
they made changes
that allowed us to leave.
Like, we literally
were held captive,
and it required the chancellor
to let you leave the school.
As a parent, as a
community, and as a person
who lives in the community,
you can share your concerns
with the superintendent.
You can share your
concerns by calling 311.
Part of it is, if they
don't know what's going on,
nothing will ever change.
I feel like as a
principal, I hold myself
to the highest regard.
Sometimes, it's to a detriment,
because if a paper didn't
go home on Monday, and
it ends up on Tuesday,
parents are like, we
didn't get the paper.
We didn't get the paper.
And I'm like, it's a paper.
Right?
But in other schools,
if it's something
like kids feeling like
they've been demoralized,
they've been shut
out of classes,
and they've been thrown out of
classes, they don't speak up.
And it's often because
of the retaliation
that they feel is going to come.
But you on the outside
can speak to that.
There's always someone
willing to listen.
It has to start with actually
telling and making that call.
So the options are,
311 and superintendent.
Those are your best options,
because anything else is not
going to make a change.
You're not going to
go into the school.
The principal's not
going to listen to you.
But those people hold
them accountable.
SPEAKER: Can I do one follow-up?
NADIA LOPEZ: Yes.
SPEAKER: What if it's been
published in "The Daily News,"
and still, nothing's happened?
NADIA LOPEZ: So you
continue to follow up.
It comes down to--
it could be in "The Daily
News," but "The Daily News" just
sometimes falls on deaf ears.
You have to be relentless.
If you're not relentless--
there are so many things
that happen in our society.
Right?
It gets published,
and nothing changes,
until people get up and start
saying this is unacceptable,
or going to the
community board meetings
and saying this is unacceptable,
or getting a group of parents
and creating a petition and
saying this is unacceptable.
You have to continue to be that
person who's going to advocate.
It doesn't require
100 people to do it,
but if two or three
people consistently do it,
someone is going to have to
say, there are people watching,
and we need to pay attention
to what's going on.
AUDIENCE: My question is,
with all the statistics
that you laid out
for Brownsville,
how do you justify or explain
teachers who have little
to no experience coming
into these communities
where 60-some-odd percent
have learning challenges
that a teacher with
little to no experience
wouldn't have been
exposed to, let
alone the cultural
differences and just all
of those challenges
that go into it?
From my point of
view, I feel like you
need experience and, sort
of, to be wet behind the ears
before you can identify that
maybe a child is being abused
in some way, or see some sort
of mental or learning challenge.
And some of that, no matter how
much school experience you get,
you only get from experience.
NADIA LOPEZ: So
couple of things--
veteran teachers are expensive.
So I would love to have a
gang load of veteran teachers,
but what they make,
their average,
would eat up my budget.
So when I'm a
smaller school, when
I'm in a position where I have
to rationalize or ration off
the money, I sit and I say,
how much money do I have.
One veteran teacher could
be the cost of two teachers,
because that's how much
they stand to make.
A veteran teacher-- for
some of them, it's $75,000.
For others, it's $125,000.
They range.
So I can't afford to have
as many veteran teachers
in the building.
That's one.
The second thing
that becomes an issue
is, people don't want
to work in those areas
because it's a challenge.
It requires a lot of energy.
If you are a parent yourself
and you have a child,
your thought process is, can I
sacrifice the time and energy
that's required to
do this, that's going
to take away from my child?
And that's something people
have to ask for themselves.
The other thing is, you have
a lot of teaching programs
that are targeted
to giving us what's
considered the
best and brightest
to go into these spaces.
But what they're learning
in the schools that
are supposed to
be preparing them
has nothing to do
with what they're
going to face in the schools
that they're going to.
So I have taken on
the daunting task
of bringing in those
teaching prep programs
and having those candidates
come and train at my school,
because I really need them
to understand what's going
to happen when they walk in.
And I'm always in the
classrooms, always supporting,
but I know what it's like,
because I was a teaching
fellow.
My first year, I
was not prepared.
In my first year, for
the first three months,
I cried every day like, I
want to go back to corporate.
Why did I do this?
Even though I'm
from Brooklyn, even
though I was born and raised
around folks who were poor
and we were struggling,
being in a classroom
is a different dynamic.
What sustained me was my faith.
What sustained me
was that I knew
someone had done it for me.
And I had a child, so I
was going to figure it out.
And what I saw was an injustice.
Everyone is not built that way.
So part of it is, no one is
asking the principals what
the challenge is.
They keep giving us
whatever they give us.
People who keep
showing up are the ones
who aren't the veteran
teachers, and so we're, kind of,
called to task to make things
work in a short amount of time.
Because when you
think about it, kids
are only in school for
30 weeks out of the year.
So it's systemic.
It's not going to
be fixed overnight.
But because of
people like me who
are in the system, who are,
like, oh, this person--
we've got to fix this and
we've got to work with them--
it helps, but there's
not enough of me.
There are really
great principals
who are trying to do it,
but there's not enough.
Because at the end of
the day, it's like,
you have so much on
your plate that you're
trying to get through, that
that just doesn't become
a fight that you have anymore.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NADIA LOPEZ: You're welcome
AUDIENCE: Hey, I just
had a quick question.
You mentioned you kept your
school open till 9:00 or 10:00
at night sometimes.
So my kids after school,
they do the basketball.
They got lots of
dads to coach that.
I ran a computer
club for my kids--
all that kind of stuff.
What do your kids do
at the school for--
I'm guessing-- like,
five hours afterwards?
NADIA LOPEZ: They're
getting tutorial services.
They're doing culinary arts.
They're doing basketball.
They're doing softball,
track, double dutch step,
and clothing design.
We have a program.
So it's not them
just hanging out.
It's actually a
structured program
through SONYC, which
is what the mayor put
as part of his initiative
for at-risk middle schools.
We have funding in place,
where they pay them directly,
to have these programs.
But if I didn't
have that, there's
also a BEACON program that
stays until 9:00 at night.
AUDIENCE: So it's, kind
of, like a hired program,
or is it parent
volunteers mostly?
NADIA LOPEZ: It's
a hired program.
We don't have parent volunteers.
And oftentimes, it goes back
to parents' limitations,
parents being comfortable,
and having something
to contribute on that level.
That's often at
times, but if a parent
has something that they could
contribute, by all means,
we accept them.
But the reality is that we
don't have that in our building.
AUDIENCE: No, it's fantastic
that you can do it.
Thank you.
NADIA LOPEZ: Thank you.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: I know
we're wrapping up,
but just to leave us with
what we can do-- what can we
all do from Google to help?
NADIA LOPEZ: So that's
always a great question.
A couple of things--
I always open my doors and
say, my kids need to see you.
They need to be able to see
individuals like yourselves
and what you're doing,
so that they can see
what their possibilities are.
That's one.
Two-- there are often
times when I have
no idea what Google can offer.
Right?
It's the superficial
things that I see.
I see that we can Google things.
I see Google Hangouts.
I see Google Docs.
I understand Scratch.
But there are other things
that Google can offer
that I have no idea exists.
So part of it is, educate
me on what that is.
My overall goal is,
one day, in a way,
to create more schools and
environments like this--
to have those
Google-type schools,
where it's about
true collaborations
and setting up a
space that doesn't
have as many constraints
as I have, because
of the co-sharing.
And really getting
people to understand,
if you partner with
organizations like Google,
Google is really willing to
take that on, and saying,
we really want to be
invested in education.
Let's create the spaces
that we do for the adults.
But it makes no sense for
you to do it for the adults
if you're not doing it
for the children who
need to grow up to become those
adults to appreciate the space.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So this was wonderful.
I truly appreciate your time.
I know some of you
have lunch or you have
projects you need to work on.
My story-- the full-out story
of how I opened up the school
and a lot of the things that I
went through personally to get
it to open--
and it wasn't easy.
It's, kind of, like, the
schools that I was in before
was, dangerous minds means
lean on me, literally.
However, had I not gone
through those experiences,
I would not be as
relentless about creating
a space where children are
safe, happy, learning to be--
not just tolerant, because
we can tolerate a lot,
but have to be accepting
of every single individual,
because that's what
humanity is about.
And so if I could do it
in Brownsville, Brooklyn
under the circumstances
that I laid out,
it can be done
anywhere in this world.
Trust and believe that.
So the story's in the
back for sale, yes.
If anybody purchases it, I'll
be more than happy to sign it.
But again, I thank
you, and thank you
for this forum here at Google.
[APPLAUSE]